annie lemay
et qui radotent d'avis
pendant ce temps là au stade vélodrome à
marseille salut brut - c'est colette
gran de supportrice de l'om d'ailleurs
ça fait à peu près cinquante huit ans
que je suis là je pouvais vous montrer
mon stade c'est un peu ma deuxième
maison parce que je n'ai manqué aucun
match où le web ce soir on reçoit bresse
on m'a trop dur tout le monde merci va
siffler bref ce cédant tradition et on
va avoir et notre équipe
[Applaudissements]
bonjour moi j'attaque tout le monde est
bon jour
tu étais déjà mis tout bien là pour
faire le cliché où mettre les bars et
les connais bien ah oui j'ai des
lunettes le body connecte à un petit
pronostic ou pas normal de ne jamais de
pronostic
voila voila ne pas le nommer parce que
je me suis parti sur
la moitié de sa cote de 3 points pendant
cinq ans colette fait partie des yankees
un ancien club de supporters de l'om
mais en 1992 elle fonde son propre
groupe
les dodgers qui compte aujourd'hui trois
mille deux cents adhérents notre slogan
nous faut pour l'om c'est fier des
serveurs fidélité un peu comme mon
maillot là qui a marqué tous et vivre et
gagner ce pull il a au moins une
quarantaine alors là on arrive à ostende
comment nous à faire une casquette une
écharpe nos maillots c'est mon mari qui
est le sien celui que j'aime peut le
mieux se souvient
tas de pêche et tradition ça représente
l'om la pêche a marqué on est très ferme
de fès et le passif voilà on arrive dans
notre merveilleux jardin tout marseille
vivaux force est ce pas le droit je suis
là devant
voilà mais après sera pas comme ça
priorat ma chaise sera fermée et brut
est ici toi du pass pour me préserver
maintenant tu vas juste au milieu d'eux
maintenant un village au sud hi mom
arrivée de notre toit
voilà enfin suite à ça c'est mes amis et
ceux qui nous surveillent qui s'il ya eu
des bagarres qui viennent la connaissez
bien non me
connais
c'est la vraie supportrice là ça dans le
sang un pilier
du virage nord japon
comme tous les matchs des panneaux
sandwich de porc
street
des fois je leur fait des gâteaux des
oreillettes la 22e jeu connu andré non
maryse et lui jouent au foot et qui voit
sa reprise allait au fond ça me plairait
et tous les bâtiments c'est qu'on est
maintenant et après mam n'est une crue
mais après il m'a toujours donné mon
meilleur souvenir c'est en 69 quand on a
fait la coupe de france contre bordeaux
à paris cent de ma fière de cinq mois et
j'ai fait c'est 02 13 je n'ai jamais vu
après celle de ma vie j'avais 27 ans et
on était ennemi là par ici à marseille
dès que tu n'aies on te prennes carthage
au vélodrome et je suis la voix de tes
parents moi j'ai 30 ans et demi c'est
toutes mes cartes d'abonnés
collectionne ayew recommande en effet
tourné movis j'ai baigné dans l'ambiance
mes parents et ma manie m'emmener au
match et que le calendrier de l'om y
sort en fait il a affiché à la maison et
quoi qu'on fasse les mutations n'est
parfois pas sens la famille les amis
pour en dresser tout est basé sur le le
calendrier de l'om le monde demandé si
je voulais donner le coup d'envoi pour
la journée de la femme
avant il n'y avait pas beaucoup de
femmes au sein du parlement
c'est dire si il faudrait voir devient
arbitre ait pas de problème madame j'ai
dit oui pas de problème d'accord mais
deux que les coûts fois ils sont pas
toujours du même côté mais je lui dis
bien pour demain et il n'a tapé sur
l'épaule il m'a dit on est tranquille à
madame je sais que ton joueur préféré la
de l'équipe maintenant ce
n'est pas le dire elle est injectée
thème veut pas y est dans mon coeur
bayer
il faut le noir et polo
one
oh
[Musique]
hu alors que yahoo
les rongeurs
je vous dis
des cadeaux une gamme
on a perdu à la sphère du baume la
prochaine qu'on va gagner et vive l'om
et nous on n'est pas désespérée voilà
les amis ne tenait pas compte amener pas
désespérée voilà
[Musique]